the probability axioms are the basic
rules of probability theory and they are
surprisingly few but they imply many
interesting properties that we will now
explore first we will see that what you
might think of as missing axioms are
actually implied by the axioms already
in place for example we have an axiom
that probabilities are non-negative we
will show that probabilities are also
less than or equal to one we have
another axiom that says that the
probability of the entire sample space
is one we will show a counterpart that
the probability of the empty set is
equal to zero this makes perfect sense
the empty set has no elements so it is
impossible there is zero probability
that the outcome of the experiment would
lie in the empty set we also have
another intuitive property the
probability that an event happens plus
the probability that the event does not
happen exhaust all possibilities and
these two probabilities together should
add to 1 for instance if the probability
of heads is 0.6 then the probability of
tails should be 0.4 finally we can
generalize the activity axiom which was
originally given for the case of two
disjoint events to the case where we're
dealing with the union of several
disjoint events by this joint here we
mean that the intersection of any two of
these events is the empty set
we will prove this for the case of three
events and then the argument generalizes
for the case where where we're taking
the union of K disjoint events where K
is any finite number so the intuition of
this result is the same as for the case
of two events but we will derive it
formally and we will also use it to come
up with a way of calculating the
probability of a finite set by simply
adding the probabilities of its in
visual elements all of these statements
that we were that we just presented are
intuitive and you do not really need to
be convinced about their validity
nevertheless it is instructive to see
how these statements follow from the
axioms that we have put in place so we
will now present the arguments based
only on the three axioms that we have
available and in order to be able to
refer to these axioms let us give them
some names call them axioms a B and C we
start as follows let us look at a sample
space and a subset of that sample space
call it a and consider the complement of
that subset the complement is the set of
all elements that do not belong to the
set a so a set together with its
complement make up everything which is
the entire sample space on the other
hand if an element belongs to a set a it
does not belong to its complement so the
intersection of a set with its
complement is the empty set now we argue
as follows we have that the probability
of the entire sample space is equal to 1
this is true by our second axiom now the
sample space as we just discussed can be
written as the union of an event and the
complement of that event this is just a
set theoretic relation and next since
the a set and it's complement are
disjoint this means that we can apply
the additivity axiom and write this
probability as the sum of the
probability of event a with the
probability of the complement of a this
is one of the relations that we had
claimed and which we have now
established based on this relation we
can also write that the probability of
an event
a is equal to one minus the probability
of the complement of that event and
because by the non-negativity axiom this
quantity here is non-negative 1 minus
something non-negative is less than or
equal to 1 we're using here the non
negativity axiom and we have established
another property namely that
probabilities are always less than or
equal to 1
finally let us note that 1 is the
probability always of a set plus the
probability of a complement of that set
and let us use this property for the
case where the set of interest is the
entire sample space now the probability
of the entire sample space is itself
equal to 1 and what is the complement of
the entire sample space the complement
of the entire sample space consists of
all elements that do not belong to the
sample space but since the sample space
is supposed to come to contain all
possible elements its complement is just
the empty set and from this relation we
get the implication that the probability
of the empty set is equal to 0 this
establishes yet one more of the
properties that we had just claimed a
little earlier we finally come to the
proof of the generalization of our
additivity axiom from the case of two
disjoint events to the case of three
disjoint events so we have our sample
space and within that sample space we
have three events three subsets and
these subsets are disjoint in the sense
that any two of those subsets have no
elements in common and we're interested
in the probability of the union of a B
and C how do we make progress we have an
additive 'ti axiom in our hands which
applies to the case of the union of two
disjoint
here we have three of them but we can do
the following trick we can think of the
union of a B and C as consisting of the
union of this blue set with that green
set formally what we're doing is that
we're expressing the union of these
three sets as follows we form one set by
taking the union of a with B and before
we have the other set C and the overall
Union can be thought of as the union of
these two sets now
since the three sets are disjoint this
implies that the blue set is disjoint
from the green set and so we can use the
add activity axiom here
to write this probability as the
probability of a union B plus the
probability of C and now we can use the
additive 'ti axiom once more since the
set a and B are disjoint to write the
first term as probability of a plus
probability of B we carry over the last
term and we have the relation that we
wanted to prove this is the proof for
the case of three events you should be
able to follow this line of proof to
write an argument for the case of four
events and so on and you might want to
continue by induction and eventually you
should be able to prove that if the sets
a 1 up to a K are disjoint then the
probability of the union of those sets
is going to be equal to the sum of their
individual probabilities so this is the
generalization to the case where we're
dealing with the union of finitely many
disjoint events a very useful
application of this comes in the case
where we want to calculate the
probability of a finite set so here we
have a sample space
and within that sample space we have
some particular elements as well as to
up to sk8 K of them and these elements
together form a finite set what can we
say about the probability of this finite
set the idea is to take this finite set
that consists of K elements and think of
it as the union of several little sets
that contain one element each so set
theoretically what we're doing is that
we're taking this set with K elements
and we write it as the union of a set
that contains just as one set that
contains just the second element as two
and so on up to the cave element we're
assuming of course that these elements
are all different from each other so in
that case these sets these single
element sets are all disjoint so using
the additivity property for a union of K
disjoint sets we can write this as the
sum of the probabilities of the
different single element sets at this
point it is usual to start abusing or
rather simplifying notation a little bit
probabilities are assigned two sets so
here we're talking about the probability
of a set that contains a single element
but intuitively we can also talk as just
the probability of that particular
element and use this simpler notation so
when using the simpler notation we will
be talking about the probabilities of
individual elements although in terms of
formal mathematics what we really mean
is the probability of this event that's
comprised only of a particular element s
one and so on